hello i'm anastasia suarez the founder
of anastasia beverly hills
well brown became i think 30 years ago
i started working as an aesthetician and
nobody in hollywood pay attention to
eyebrows and i remember my art teacher
that was telling me if i want to draw a
portrait and i want to change an emotion
i just change
eyebrows there were no products for
eyebrows and i started working and
developing
products to solve solution for every
problem that everyone
including myself had i admire eyebrows
of so many of my clients
and i could say oprah winfrey jennifer
lopez
kim kardashian victoria beckham
amal clooney and so many more there are
so many artists that
are incredible and i admire their
eyebrows
my dream is to do the queen's eyebrows
i hope one day my best hack for a
feather brow is the brow pen
i created this product to mimic
hair strokes so you could mimic those
hair strokes and create really feathery
and thick eyebrows if you want or if you
are missing eyebrows hair
this is the product that will create
that
double the size of your natural eyebrow
if you want my advice
for growing bigger eyebrows is just let
the eyebrow grow one row at a time
so stop tweezing one row you fill in
with powder or pencil and you highlight
the short real short hairs you could
cover those
with the highlighter and once that
row of hair grows then you let another
row of hair
so it depends how thick you want your
eyebrows the biggest brow myth i like to
bust is that one
brow fits all so every eyebrow
should be personalized according your
bone structure and natural eyebrow shape
this is the base of our technique
anastasia eyebrow technique
the biggest brow blunder i want people
to
be aware is over tweezing the easiest
brow sheet
is using the brow freeze this is the
newest innovation in our collection
and it's a wax that will give you the
ability
of creating that laminated look soap
brow look that everybody
is really fun of lately but this
is the best formula
[Music]
my left eyebrow is done is a little bit
darker but i want you to see
better the the products that i'm gonna
use
and my right eyebrow is not done
so i need to establish first of all my
golden ratio where my eyebrow should
begin and where should end
above middle of inside of the nostril
i put a mark right there this is where
my eyebrows should begin
outside corner of my nose corner of my
eyes
that should be the end of my eyebrows
tip of my nose middle of my iris this
should be the highest part
i start with the brow freeze the brow
styling wax
i smear this product and
the spoolie i tap a little bit so i
don't need too much product
i start using the product from
the highest part of my eyebrows
towards the end and i do the same thing
here i want to make sure
the hair every hair has some styling wax
i'm going to use the brow powder and
i'm going to use a little brown freeze
on the brush the apple
angle cut brush and i need just to
touch a little bit the the color the
powder
so i will start using
almost like strokes of hair very little
because we have the brow freeze i barely
touch the skin with the the other brush
the spoolie
i brush through because i want to
give myself a very natural look so i
have the base
with the brow powder and brow freeze
now i take the brow pen in soft brown
you have to shake it very well you start
from the highest part mimicking hair
strokes
this is an incredible product
my next step will be the pro pencil
and i could use
much more hair from the highest part
towards the end and with the brush
20 i'm gonna
blend right now the product
after i finish that the spoolie
i will brush again and why i do this
because i want the spoolie the brush to
take a little bit of the highlighter and
bring in between the hair strokes that i
created with the brow pen to give me
more natural look brow definer it's easy
to use
you just draw a line here here
and then in between you could go like
this
almost like flick the pencil and
as a finishing touch i use clear brow
gel
clear brow gel sets the color holds the
hair
and separates beautifully the hair and
gives a very natural looking
brow
[Music]
i would like to share with you a few of
my favorite
beauty products let's start with hair
during the pandemic i have i had to
color my own hair i found that this is
the best
the best blow dryer is can
pavus of course he put my name here
because he loves me and i love him
my favorite hot curling iron is ghd
i wish they would make a thicker one
this is only one inch
this is my favorite masks
crystal frog in line hair care line is
amazing hand creme barbra stern of
course
i use all her skincare line
very nice beautiful everything
you want you could find in her line i
like them
skinceuticals of course some of my
eyebrow products just you because you
know we have so many
tom ford i love his candles his perfume
frederik mal is genius and i love his
all his perfume but this is me thank you
glamour uk for having me answering all
those questions
about eyebrows